I don't have any friends.
See you!
I mean zero friends.
Because I'm totally different
from other people.
I'm an entirely different creature.
How could you make friends
in that situation?
In spite of that...
Hey, dude!
Let's go eat some ramen noodles.
Come with me, Saiki.
I feel disturbance in the air.
Two people are stalking me now.
It sucks. I have lived
trying not to draw attention.
-Why are you following us?
-Should I change schools?
You wanna eat ramen noodles with us?
I never said I would.
Just go slurp them by yourself.
You're the one following us.
We are going to investigate
the disturbance in the air.
Get lost!
I never said I would.
Just go feel it by yourself.
Huh? You get lost! We're gonna eat ramen!
Go eat by yourself! Let's go, Saiki!
I can feel it's getting worse.
-We're gonna eat ramen!
-We gotta settle it down!
I never said I would!
It looks like they're
going out of business soon.
Saiki, how come you're friends with him?
I'm telling you as your partner,
you should give it a second thought.
I'm not your partner.
Dude, you should quit being his friend.
I'm telling ya as your BFF.
I'm not your BFF. Why don't you guys
become friends with each other, then?